Joining us today.
We have Pejman knows ad and Mar Hershenson,
two of the most respected venture capitalists in Silicon Valley.
In 2013 they teamed up to create page one mark and together invested in over 30
startups including door dash,
garden health branch and Gusto.
Just last year they announced their second round of funding of $75 million and
rebranded to pair on the who we are section of pairs website are the following
words.
We understand what it means to build something from nothing.
That journey defines each of our life stories.
We are immigrants having come to America penniless,
but with big ideas.
We've been entrepreneurs determined to build great companies.
We know now that success emerges only for those who have endured setbacks and
overcome hurdles.
We've learned from our failures and we know what it takes to succeed.
There are no shortcuts when it comes to building something extraordinary.
All of this finds expression in our work.
That quote speaks to what I think makes pair stand out among venture capital
firms and it reflects the unique personal background.
That page mon in Mar experience.
I'm very excited that both of you are here with us today.
And maybe we can get started by having you share a little bit about your
background,
where you grew up,
your career pathways,
and how you got into venture capital and we can see how your experiences
reflected in pairs mission statement.
Awesome.
That's my seniors just started ladies first.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
I think [inaudible] has a great story,
but I'll go with my first.
I'm originally from Barcelona,
Spain and I apologize for my cold.
Um,
I came to the u s in [inaudible] 95,
uh,
do do a masters at Stanford and I ended up getting a phd in electrical
engineering.
This was 1999 and I was ready to go to academia.
I had already lined up a job professor job and at the last minute and the crazy
time of 1999,
I decided to,
uh,
you know,
reject that offer and go do a startup.
And that was my first startup.
Um,
my phd was in circuit design in con,
you know,
analog chip designers was fairly technical and I also,
um,
did comebacks optimization,
large scale optimization.
So I had kind of a dual background for somebody in chips.
Um,
my first company actually didn't work out,
but it was great learning ground for everything that came afterwards.
And after that I did two companies that did work out.
Uh,
so that was great.
Throughout my journey I met Pejman patch.
Mine was,
I'm an investor in my second company and I remember going to pitch to Pesh Mine
and saying after my,
my first company had failed.
And you know,
I'm wondering who would give me money and patch mine.
I said,
depending on what I'm working on,
this is,
I've learned all of uh,
what customers want.
I'm building this software platform using convex optimization for designing
chips and passionate and said,
I have no idea what you're talking about,
but I really like you.
So I want to give you money and I will have my friends talk to you.
And if they like you,
I'll just put around together.
And this was in 2004 and in 2000 a lot has changed since 2004.
In 2004 there was,
um,
I think maybe tech crunch had started,
but there was no angel lists.
There was no sense of like,
uh,
Angel Investing as a sport.
It was really like a few people and you would have to raise by going to their
big houses.
Nobody was in a coffee shop coding or you know,
it was very,
very different.
So,
but Pejman was,
they're doing this from a very,
you know,
or at least stay every early point in this,
in,
in this seed movement that we have right now.
So anyways,
that's how I got to know patch mine.
And he approached me,
he approached me in 2010 with this idea of doing a house where we could work
with founders and help them build companies.
And it took about almost four years for me to like pull the plug and say,
great,
let's go do this.
But that's how we got,
I got started into venture.
Oh well thank you for very much.
It's funny,
I I I look at myself,
I don't have a tech background.
I would have been investment background.
I'm a venture capitalist,
so that tells you a little bit more about my background.
So I,
um,
came 24 years ago from Iran here,
I didn't speak any English and I didn't want to come to America.
My brother just pushed me to come here and I ended up going to San Carlos
because my uncle lived there.
I had $700.
I lost all the money because I was calling the girl in Iran that I really love
that I thought if I don't call her,
I lose her.
So,
and at that time was like $4 per minute.
So because of the payphones,
so I had,
there was no Google for none of these things today.
So,
um,
I ended up,
my first job was washing cars in America and then ended up getting a job at the
yogurt shop in Redwood City and,
and I slipped in an ethic above the yogurt shop because I want to save money,
go marry the girl that I love.
So,
um,
and one of these nights I was studying English.
I sign add that medallion rug gallery in downtown Palo Alto is hiring
salespeople.
So I ended up being a salesperson at that rug gallery and I became very good at
selling carpets and Persian carpets are very,
very expensive.
So you don't sell him at the gallery,
you go take him to people's home.
So after a few years in,
in one year,
I sold $8 million worth of carpet,
which is like really unheard of.
But that tells the scope of the sales and the relationship we have with our
customers.
But you know,
in late nine is I figured out all of my customers are CEOs,
venture capitalist,
you know,
families of big companies.
And I was amazed by the amount of value they're creating,
not only nice homes and nice cars and the ability to buy cars was just really
building companies based on knowledge.
And you know,
I,
I thought that I'd want to be one of fit and that I thought maybe this is the
opportunity for me.
I'm having a job and the most important streak maybe in the most important time
of my life.
And I started to educate,
educate myself,
and I learned about the ecosystem and thinking about this as nineties,
late nineties,
it was no tech crunch,
no YC,
no blogging.
So the way I did it,
I started to put lot of events and networking events at our place and the deal
flow start to kick in.
And we started to invest.
I convinced the owner of the rug gallery to start to invest with me.
I didn't have money,
so he started it and we've made horrible mistakes,
but I became very,
very lucky nine months into it to meet Maurice Husband and Andy Rubin.
This was dangerous.
So Andy came one day to buy carpets and I was like really in awe this guy.
It was how he talks about the future.
And then I said,
I'm angel investing and nobody was giving them money.
So somehow I became the first investor in Anglian math and Joe Britt and as you
know,
Andy went on and go android.
Um,
I'm actually the only person in rural gives android a term sheet where we didn't
agree on terms with.
So you could be a good investor but miss big opportunities.
So fast forward I ended up being an investor in the first investor in Dropbox
lending club.
They injured and many others and in around 2011 12 after like 1112 years doing
this,
I felt that uh,
companies are raising a million dollar bus.
Nobody's helping founders.
And you know,
I thought given my background and network,
it's an,
it's a huge opportunity to build an institution to help founders on ground zero.
And I wanted to partner with somebody who build companies.
I have a deep tech background and have same philosophy in life.
So I've reached out to mar and I tried to convince her for a few years and you
know,
we built this partnership,
you're kind of ying and Yang,
you know,
I'm college rough house,
she's a Stanford fuge time.
I invested in a hundred 20th startups before the starting the fund.
Mar invested in only one but very the skills and the same philosophy in life,
like helping people and really be good.
Give first before you get.
And I think it remains to be seen,
but peer is now perhaps at the,
you know,
center of ecosystem here in the valley to just help founders on really early
stages.
If you have done so many different probes that we can talk about it and it's,
it's amazing to be here.
I remember,
you know,
my partners are own Medallian rug reality.
They're owned one 65 university avenue,
the lucky building.
Google started there.
So I saw Google their number hundred 20 versus today,
I don't know how many thousand people.
So it's pretty amazing to be part of this community.
We are really honored and humbled.
Pejman you mentioned that you worked at the rug shop and then you sort of use
that opportunity to transition into doing a VC by working with your clients.
I think in Silicon Valley a lot of the times there's a divide between tech
employees or tech workers and everyone else.
So maybe you wouldn't have necessarily CEO speaking,
forming genuine
relationships with people working at a coffee shop or a serving tables at a
restaurant.
Um,
we're working in sales at a store.
So how were you able to bridge that divide that exists?
You know,
I think I'm good at making friends.
So once you become friends with these people,
that lesson too.
So I wasn't going to people's home selling carpets the same time,
say I'm investing as good together.
Uh,
it was just building the relationship and I was very,
uh,
paying a lot of attention to build that very concrete relationship with my,
you know,
my customers who are like few of them are advisors to our fun now and then a few
of them invested for our funds,
so there became LP North Fund.
So it's very important to build this very authentic relationship with whoever
you work with.
Um,
so that,
that was the genesis of my relationship with my clients.
We'll became going investor with me.
He also throw great parties.
Yes,
you're a party.
Everyone loves Persian food.
So whenever people come to throwing great parties as a secret and inviting their
spouses,
then everybody goes home.
And Mark,
you mentioned that you did a start up that initially didn't do well.
Uh,
one of the questions that comes up when I talk about startups with my friends,
a lot of them being people of Color and women is that they're concerned that
especially for first time founders,
there is some bias from the VC world.
And I was wondering if you experienced any of that during your first startup and
to what extent?
You know,
it wasn't very different time.
I think when I,
when I left school,
which is the year 2000,
the standard way of doing a company,
whether you were a female or you know or not,
didn't really matter.
There was a tech person and the standard was we'll bring a CEO to run the
company and you will be the CTO.
And you know,
that's the way companies were run at the time.
And it has changed a lot right now.
That's not the philosophy.
People that understand that in good companies,
the CTO,
the founder stays with the company all the way and they're the CEO and they're
the one driving the company.
And that's what Pashman and I believe,
you know,
I think we are,
we,
we invest in a lot of companies where the founders are either just out of
school.
So it's definitely first time founders or maybe there are a few years out of
school and they've had a couple of jobs,
but it's their first day.
And that's what I see we're really good at,
which is taking people that are amazing and then teaching them how to your
fares,
sales pitch and fundraise.
It's not rocket science.
I think smart people can learn it with the right support.
And that's our role.
Right.
Um,
so anyways,
that's us.
I did an encounter any sort of,
you know,
issues or I didn't feel them.
Let me say that when I was fundraising or not.
It's more,
you know,
I probably was more in the workplace,
but not when I was
a founder in the role of a founder.
And do you think,
I know you worked at Stanford,
yeah.
Machine,
in addition to doing your phd,
did that experience in academia,
do you think that helped you with during VC work now?
A surprisingly yes.
Um,
you know,
actually when I used to teach circuit design,
so it's very tacky.
But you know,
you're really,
a lot of what we do is teaching in some way is transferring knowledge.
Sometimes it's our knowledge,
sometimes it's transferring knowledge of other people to our founders.
So,
um,
it's similar to what you do when you are either guiding somebody in a research
project or teaching them maybe once a transistor for the first time.
Uh,
there's a lot of that,
you know,
coaching that we do and you do this.
I did the same at Stanford for many,
many years.
So yes.
And I want to talk about that.
So I mean,
giving credit to Mara and then the bringing,
being a lecturer and a founder and having a deep technical expertise really
helped for us to really understand the opportunities exist and really help
founders.
One of our portfolio companies is a company called one concern to just close it,
massive $20 million series a.
And then,
you know,
Mara really found them as a poster session at Stanford.
They were,
they were pitching their phd thesis and Marissa and opportunity that,
that the groundbreaking technology they have,
they can convert it to a commercial company.
They didn't believe it.
They came to our office.
And then fast forward now are becoming a media category defining company.
You guys have done a lot of work at Stanford,
especially with the garage program,
trying to get students to make startups during the summer and see if they can go
even further beyond the summer work they do.
Di Did you decide that you wanted to work with students before starting that
program or was the success that you saw in that program sort of the driver for
the work that you do,
the outreach that you do now?
Um,
let Pejman talk,
you know,
I think there's,
there,
there are few backgrounds at history.
So when I started to be like,
man,
I ain't started investing in Andy.
I need a few million dollars to start today.
Basically you don't need money to start.
As long as there's a laptop,
there's a Starbucks and you know,
AWS and Google drive,
then you don't die.
You can start a company.
So for that I needed so much capital out there.
So there's a lot of noise.
If you're a seed investor like us,
how do you look at this landscape of so many founders?
How do you pick the winners?
Um,
so luckily Mara and I started the fund because of our background with a very
good deal flow.
But uh,
we thought it in order to increase the quality of our deal flow,
it's great to go inside communities that are already filtered.
And Stanford was the obvious choice.
Plus Mar was there.
And then I found a few companies and the first thing we wanted to build the
community over that and we thought it would be great that actually Mara Life for
the garage program,
we didn't have any business value.
We thought if you have like exceptional students under one roof,
something good will.
So yeah,
no,
you had to go ahead.
It's a garage is a program that every year we select up to 20 students from
Stanford,
from,
it could be freshman all the way to your graduate or post doc.
Right.
And basically these are typically people in computer science and engineering
departments.
You don't need to have an idea as long as you want to be an entrepreneur.
So we select these 20 students for nine months while academic year we give you a
space mentorship and we really help you find problems you're passionate to solve
and help you build the product.
No expectation to build the company,
no expectation to fundraise but naturally happen.
So this is the fourth year we are doing it and we don't take any equity in these
companies.
We don't invest.
We give him a lot of resources.
They come to our office once every two weeks to checking,
meet our team and their mentors.
And already six companies came out of it.
One of them is our portfolio company.
One was sold to uh,
Palentier more actually negotiated the terms with Fallon therapy.
It makes $0 million,
but those two founders came back and did our founders,
our portfolio companies.
And because of that,
I think this community is growing.
And you know,
the philosophy you give before you get your kind of under the skin of Stanford
now.
And we see things before.
Anybody else
as part of your mission statement that's on pairs website,
you also mentioned that she wanted to recruit it to him,
but he didn't call me.
I had a lot on my plate.
Uh,
in Paris mission statement.
You also mentioned that you're looking for founders that have unusual
backgrounds.
Can you speak a little bit to why you decide to focus on that aspect of founders
and maybe some examples of what you mean by unusual backgrounds?
Yeah.
You know,
I think venture is really interesting because,
um,
especially for engineers,
I think it's very interesting.
On the first time I went into venture I said,
oh,
I'll just like look at all the variables about like what makes a company
successful.
So I spent a bunch of time collecting data on actually semiconductor companies.
So we're a decade and you know,
I would like record.
I think I had like maybe 40 variables per company.
And then I did some simple regression and I tried a few models anyways.
Uh,
and you're like,
great,
I have a model and now I can predict what's the next winter.
Right on.
It's almost the opposite.
We are a business off exceptions,
truly have exceptions.
And the really,
really big winners,
they are just almost unpredictable,
right?
So on,
it's almost interesting,
but you know,
um,
I'll tell you,
you know,
that the movie about Facebook came out on for a while,
then people thought,
oh,
I must just fun dropouts from,
uh,
MIT or Stanford and well are guaranteed to hit a success.
Right?
And you know,
now people are kind of coming back out of that and saying,
no,
maybe you should find people in their thirties and they're more successful.
So anyways,
um,
I,
my,
you know,
the bottom line is that there's no formula.
I think everybody's different.
Um,
and we really liked people that,
you know,
they're,
they're almost like unusual and they've not gone a straight path.
Uh,
you know,
so,
for example,
you know,
somebody,
we just hired somebody who was a chef for some time.
Some of our,
one of our founders,
um,
who runs a big company called Mimi Boston ecommerce companies,
very large in Asia.
He was,
you know,
in Afghanistan for awhile.
And he was an engineer.
But the Sida,
he truly wanted to go into fashion and went to the Parsons school and worked for
Tom Ford.
So it's somebody that it was not like,
you know,
something that you would predict easily.
So anyways,
that's a,
everybody's different.
This company that Panama was mentioned in one concern,
which basically they're using artificial intelligence to predict and case of an
earthquake or a flood where the big damage is.
So you can send emergency responders very easily and you can do prevention,
right?
So this guy,
you know,
as from Kashmir,
he lives in,
he,
he lived all his life and this little village,
he suffered earthquakes,
floods.
He spent literally like five days on the roof of his home.
Um,
and he knew that he wanted to actually do something to avoid being in the same
situation again.
So again,
just somebody with a special background that you want to fund and contribute.
And I don't know if you want something to add.
You know,
I think on a broader spectrum,
you'll,
if you look at the venture capital community,
there are a lot of people claim to venture capitalists,
but they're more capitalist,
venture Catholic.
And,
and the reason is,
I mean,
especially when you combine the,
actually I met another person yesterday,
they said,
um,
I said,
well,
how do you look at companies you said is no product risk and then no market
risk.
So,
and I thought,
wow,
so how can be a venture capitalist to do this things?
So,
and in our business you live for the moment that somebody walks at your door and
surprise you and you break all the rules.
Um,
you know,
no terms is important.
Everything you've learned doesn't fit there.
I really want to partner with that particular person.
And if you look at the biggest company ever created,
the founders very in that category.
So there's probably people here in this room that may be interested in doing a
startup at some point,
or maybe people watching online.
And you went a little bit into this with talking about finding people who are
special and unusual.
But in terms of the type of company or how a company approaches the market,
do you have anything that you look for in the companies and startups that you
were,
uh,
funding?
Maybe let me say something else about the founders because it's,
it's not,
you know,
it's not only like,
hey,
you have a,
uh,
an unusual background.
We take you,
it's not just like that.
Um,
I think the founders that we work with at the very beginning,
just imagine you are in our position,
there's people that come in,
they have nothing.
There might be a prototype,
but there's really nothing.
Right.
And they come in and they're like,
we want money to build our business and we think it's going to be great.
So,
um,
you know,
we're just judging that a founder or founders.
Right.
And one of the characteristics that I think is very important is this,
people are so mission driven.
They're obsessed with what they're doing.
It's like they can't sleep at night because they have to go to this company.
And I think when you're obsessed and completely mission driven,
there's a lot of other things that fall from it,
right?
Like your focus,
then you know,
you're spending all your time doing this and so on that really matter.
But this obsession is really,
really important.
And I'll go back to your question about I think the market,
um,
you know,
sometimes there's no market but we can fast and companies we just don't even
know.
You know,
you're creating a new market.
So for us it's hard to look at even a financial model or unit economics or
margins or anything.
We just have to believe that you could get there.
Right?
Um,
but we liked people that almost like how a police action driven,
so they have a plan.
So it's not randomly things happen.
They're like,
Hey,
I'm going to try this.
Almost like a math mind.
I'm like,
I'm trying to have some sort of hypotheses and it might not work and it might
work,
but if not,
I'm going to try this.
And so on and taught and,
right.
And it's almost like this constant learning loop that they have.
And it's not just like I'm doing a company and let's see what happens.
Basically.
Go ahead.
No,
what are you think smart?
Like when you look at the founders would be like to work with are some common
characteristics.
We like founders or really close to the problem they're solving.
Typically even people come and they said we had 20 ideas narrowed down to 10 and
we pick this one.
It's kind of a red flag.
He liked people who have lived through that problem or they have academic
background or you have faced those challenges here at Google.
You're building a good product,
but do you see a huge opportunity to do something?
So we really want to see that.
We liked the teams who have,
um,
you know,
history together,
uh,
the,
or broke that Google or the rock climb every weekend or they went to the same
high school.
And as,
as Mara mentioned,
people who have a vision,
many founders,
they think they have a vision,
but it just having a goal of raising more money in two years.
So it's a very different,
and we pay lots of attention to figure out why you're doing this.
I think most of most of startup doesn't work.
Why,
why you want to go through these things.
And it's,
it's a very important question that we ask.
Um,
and so it was combination of characteristic of the founders we want to see in
the teams that you're working with them has been a lot of talk recently in the
news about the importance of company culture and making sure that you foster a
good culture from an early stage because otherwise in the long run potentially
you could be facing problems.
So since you guys work with early stage companies,
are there things that you see that can be done since the beginning of a company
to help create that good culture?
To avoid problems?
Yeah,
I think everybody talks about it and nobody defines what it is.
And the culture.
I mean in the scope of Google,
the days when,
when your startup,
what is it?
Is it a ping pong table or is free food and,
and I think it should be defined by the founding team.
And I think culture could be different in any set of companies,
but it's set of principles that you believe in and you stick to it.
And it could be very different.
And you know,
one of the companies are broke like 10 years ago.
It was an amazing CEO and the culture was all about transparency.
And I remember it every Friday they had barbecue and he put himself in front of
the company and everybody can ask any question from the cur,
criticize him.
That's one way to do it.
The other way is,
you know,
people say that is all about our customers.
I think we should service them in.
So this is a set of different principles that you should create and you should
stick to it.
But I seen them,
most of us to spend the time doing it.
The second time you have a company you realize that's really,
really,
really important.
And when you have this principles,
it almost applies to everything.
How you recruit,
how you treat your customers,
how you run your meeting.
So it's super critical to have that conversation and you can get help get
coaches to exactly what that means because if you've never done it,
maybe just don't know how to do it,
but critical.
And do you have any advice for people who are,
uh,
in early stage companies trying to get funding,
particularly maybe if they come from immigrant backgrounds,
if they're people of color or women talk to us first?
Yes.
Um,
yeah,
I think the most,
you know,
I think the great thing about the valley,
especially if you're here all right,
um,
is that you can get a lot of help.
People are typically very,
very helpful.
So,
um,
you know,
you're like almost,
even a block away from anybody that can,
you know,
help you either with your business plan or is this a good idea or not?
Or research you can get out there these days.
There's so many things for founders and entrepreneurs and events.
I think passionate and I can be out every night and every day meeting people.
So I think if you really start from nothing,
I would say,
you know,
I reach out for help to your network.
And I think a lot of times people are really hesitant to reach out.
But I've been surprised how responsive people are to an email or even if you
like tweet them,
they might reply and then you start fostering a relationship over time.
I think one of the things that's so important for founders to know is that
there's a lot of rejection when you do entrepreneurship,
whether it's raising money or getting our customers.
Sometimes people will come,
it's like,
oh,
I've read,
I've sent a 500 emails are through Linkedin and I got two responses and they're
like devastated.
I'm like,
well,
you got to,
that's awesome.
Right?
So,
and it's really hard at the beginning to get somebody to listen to you,
but the good founders,
because they're obsessed,
they don't give up.
Right.
And they're like,
okay,
maybe linkedin was not the right way.
I should do this other thing or whatever.
Anyway,
so same when you start,
do you approach uh,
how you look at first time founders differently than how you approach people who
have had several startups potentially or who have pivoted?
Know our approach is not a different the same way,
but obviously the,
at different stages you need different types of help.
If you are in a second or third time founder or maybe you need an introduction
from us to a see you off a public company and they take it.
But if you're a first time founder you need to put an operations plan together
with us.
So it all depends of the maturity of the founders.
So you,
and we've worked with both of them.
If you look at our portfolio companies,
you have a lot of first time founder,
but we have founding team that are second or third time they're starting to
come.
Okay.
Another thing that I really appreciate about pair as a firm is that you place a
lot of emphasis on the immigrant experience and especially right now in today's
political climate,
I think that's really important.
And it's also very courageous.
And I was wondering if there's been any impact from the current political
climate on your work with pair of,
you've seen maybe changes in the people who are pitching to you or any changes
in the people that ultimately get funded.
Okay.
You know,
I think the impact is on our companies.
Yeah.
I see him.
We have founders that can't go home.
Um,
and you know,
I,
that's a big deal.
If you can't go home to see your sister get married,
I think that's a big deal.
Right.
So,
um,
at a personal level,
you know,
we've had to,
try to,
you know,
I'm went on to have a large immigration department and like maybe your HR,
like Google does.
Right.
So we've gotten involved on,
you know,
how to help them.
But,
um,
so that at a,
you know,
we have stories that have happened without,
we don't,
haven't seen necessarily a change in the people that come pitch to us,
cause you know,
they're either,
some of them are,
um,
either on an h one or they're just finishing school.
So then an n o p t visas or whatnot but passionate and I are experts are writing
all these letters of recommendation that you know,
for our founders and I think a lot of them are,
have been able to get them anyways.
It's not good news cause mine is very uh,
you know,
committed to this cost.
I came 24 years ago as an Iranian and Muslim and my immigration status after I
came was unknown.
But you know,
American never judged me I think gave me all the opportunity to thrive and I
still feel the same thing.
I hope this spirit of America is,
stays debate when I arrived here 24 years ago.
And I think if you look at this room even,
um,
and what Google people doing in Silicon Valley is just a testament of that
spirit.
[inaudible]
I think sometimes it can be difficult to bring up once background or maybe make
connections to things like your immigrant background.
Given the political climate,
how do you approach deciding when to speak up about something or what to say in
response to certain issues?
How do you balance those things?
I was learned to stand up for my rights and whatever it is.
And I think very car is,
it's a great country that your,
your voice is heard.
If you just raise your voice.
I'm not hesitant to raise my voice when I want to stand up for my rights.
And when you do that,
do that,
do you see support from fellow people in the industry or have there been
instances?
Yeah,
very much so.
I think especially in the valley,
you get so much support from the people here.
I mean it's almost everybody's immigrant to grandfather back with three.
So No,
I've got to always have a huge support and I still,
even though the political climate is changed by Trump,
um,
I know,
just don't feel it in Silicon Valley's happening is the same silicon valley.
I know for last 24 years.
What as mark mentioned is just very difficult.
I think.
Um,
you know,
I'm from Iran and Iran,
um,
has a university I think by here,
has gone to at Sharif University,
has the highest acceptance of Phd at Stanford,
the devil lead department at Marvin.
Yes.
People are deciding not to come here,
they go to Canada.
I go to,
to England.
So I think at the end America is losing a lot of amazing talents from all over
the world.
[inaudible]
and by maybe I should say something,
I think sometimes we do get founders that come and say I have a visa issue or,
and I think passionate and I once we find somebody we want,
we'll do whatever we can to help this person.
It's not snow,
snow show stopper for us,
you know,
someone will try whatever we can to get them in.
I know both of you are really focused on giving back to the communities that you
identify with.
And I was just wondering if maybe you could tell us a little bit about the ways
in which you give back and your experience about why you do it and what you get
from it.
Yeah.
I think if we think of as the garage program,
that's an example of that.
How much time and effort it takes from us and uh,
without any specific requests of owning any,
um,
ownership in this companies.
So that really tells that we really wanted to give back,
at least that particular community.
Um,
you know,
it's specific Umar even though some of the companies we don't want to invest,
she spent so much time.
If there's a company that we like them to,
Stanford GSB,
business school founders,
they wanted to get to YC and then mark spent the last two weeks coaching them
how to get the YC and they got to YC yesterday.
So I think that that tells you that you're all about helping founders at the
core
and you also don't necessarily see someone joining another firm as a negative.
No,
no.
I mean,
I
think it's a big world.
Companies lasts for a long time,
so you never know.
Right.
And I found her,
you know,
it's rare that you stay in a company forever.
You have many companies inside of you.
So we at the end,
you know,
just wanting people to do well.
That's how I,
I see the world anyways.
One company is not gonna make or break us.
Right.
Do you have any [inaudible] was Google.
Yeah,
exactly.
That was a spy out hold the cuff.
Do you have any stories about companies that you funded that you particularly
saw great success in and maybe the qualities reflected in their success?
Um,
yeah,
maybe I'll talk about my,
the first company we actually did out of the fund,
it's called branch metric.
It's,
it's a deep linking platform.
And,
um,
I met them when they were students at school and so there were students,
it was November,
so they were students,
we're still a long time,
but the CEO presented what they were doing at the time,
which was a mobile app to print the pictures,
um,
which is completely different from a deep linking up.
But they came and I rushed Depeche mode and they said,
[inaudible],
we have to fund this guy.
I,
I don't,
I don't really know what he's doing,
but he's a great,
and I'm sure he's going to figure it out.
Right.
So,
um,
that's how we got into branch.
Um,
he,
they basically pivoted twice until they did what they did.
But why did I sing and that first meeting that this guy,
you know,
would be a great CEO and was not going to stop.
Right.
Um,
he is what I call a data driven CEO.
So everything he says is almost has a number and a reason why,
uh,
so it's not hand wavy and he has done his homework and he kind of knows where
he's going.
That's why I was like,
I wanna work for this guy because I know that,
you know,
we are going to go somewhere and if we don't get there,
he'll turn around and figure it out.
And that's basically what he did.
I mean,
it's pretty impressive.
Uh,
you know,
the success of the company was not an accident.
Uh,
the company pivoted twice into what they're doing and it was all really
literally data driven decisions.
You know,
they're not getting in our customers,
oh,
maybe we should build an Sdk for printing.
Oh,
how do we get people to install it and open it in the right place?
And that's how they eventually got into the blinking.
Um,
anyways,
so that's one story.
I have many pesh mine.
Um,
um,
I think you mentioned that if you were telling me page one,
you start and get fund and you invest in the Korean cosmetic product and would
have said I would never do it but until you meet,
you know,
the founders of Mimi box.
So as mark mentioned,
he studies computer science and Korea.
Uh,
then decided to go to
serve in peace corporate Afghanistan,
then decided to go to work for Tom Ford and figure out that Korean cosmetic
product people love it is after France is the second biggest market in the world
of Korean cosmetic periscope on cheaper,
same quality.
And he wanted to build in the brand that serves the entire world in fast forward
this year there,
you know,
making a lot of money,
they might go public.
So his desire to build something in a market that is so saturated,
it was just stunning.
And the quality of the found the who walks through the walls to make things
happen.
It was just really,
really obvious in him.
May I say one more founder's story cause I think those are the best stories.
Not really ours,
but we have a company called Aurora solar and it's founded by two immigrants
Monas actually from Kenya.
And the other one is from Germany.
Um,
this guy's met,
um,
at Stanford,
but the guy from Kenya,
he had started a solar installation company in,
you know,
in his home country.
And he was trying to actually,
uh,
you know,
when he came here,
he tried to turn it into a business.
So they realize that all this solar installation was very manual and you know,
they could actually automate it.
We software today,
they're the number one software use for any solar solar installation is actually
super,
super tacky at impressive.
Um,
but anyways,
this guy,
I,
uh,
this was in 2013 and time flies,
but in 2013 if you said solar,
people were like,
oh no,
we can't talk to you.
Right.
So,
um,
they were not,
they could not get any money.
They could not get any place to live or,
you know,
like work out of,
etc. So this guy,
you know,
Sam,
the founder,
called us like,
you know,
almost begging,
please let day in your office because we don't have anywhere to go.
And,
um,
you know,
that's how we met him.
But you know,
just the fact that he had the courage to come and say,
I don't have anything and nobody really cares,
but you know,
lend me a hand.
That was like a big deal.
Uh,
so again,
this the sort of mentality that I'm going to work and so I want to bring solar
energy to Kenya and I want to solve it and I'm working on this problem.
I'm not going to give up.
Right.
So anyways,
and,
and last year they were chosen number one software company and solar entire
solar industry.
Huh.
Oh,
wow.
You're both
talked about founders being very passionate about specific industries or
specific products.
Do you have anything,
any opinion with regard to people who maybe aren't working on something that
they're passionate about but they're doing it because maybe their financial
circumstances require them to work in that or maybe they're trying to build up
the skills to then do something that they're passionate about.
Uh,
do you think there's a certain point in which doing that for too long can be a
bad thing?
And at what point do you make the decision to actually do something you're
passionate
about?
I mean,
it really depends on people,
but I do think I do encourage people that the students that come out of school
to go get a job and learn something,
you know,
it's not my recommendation to go do a company right now,
right after school.
It has to be a very,
very special situation because I think you learn a lot by,
you're not done right after school.
You're not completely done right.
You are learning for the first five to 10 years of your career.
Just really learning.
So the place,
you know,
we pay so much attention as to what college we go,
but I think the impact in your careers,
the first job you have is much more impactful than necessarily what college you
went to.
So,
um,
you know,
I'm totally supportive of that.
And then that's the advice I give to most people.
Right?
I think at some point in your life it gets really,
really hard to go to a startup because of the circumstance of life.
You know,
you're making a lot of money.
You have a family,
maybe you're the only person in your family that's working,
so it's just harder.
Right?
Again,
people that are super obsessed,
they figure it out,
right?
I mean,
humans are very capable,
uh,
but it's harder,
right?
Anyways,
you know,
my,
the same philosophy as mar has,
I mean I think sometimes you do a job that just pays for the bill and the
family.
You might not really passionate,
but I think you can balance it.
If you like art,
you can spend your weekend doing art.
If you like soccer,
like me,
you can play soccer.
So I think Google is really good at it.
It's 80,
20 things.
I don't know,
still going around or not,
but I think in balance your life,
how are we still find your personal projects?
What about looking forward into the tech industry as a whole?
Do you see any specific areas that have a potential for high growth in the
coming years?
I mean,
um,
I let mark talk about the,
the platform she be things is the future AI,
but I think it's,
um,
I think,
we don't know.
I think our motto is investors don't create future entrepreneurs do and we stick
to it.
You think always entrepreneurs sees they see future before us.
Um,
and we don't want to corner in ourself in any particular sector.
And that's one of the reasons if you look at our portfolio companies,
we have companies all over the map.
And the reason is we really believe in the founders were solving a real problem
in a big market.
Yeah.
It's really hard to predict the future,
to be honest.
It's really hard.
Um,
and you know,
I know,
and there's a bad,
you know,
we are surrounded by great investors that have thesises and so on,
and sometimes they get it right,
sometimes they don't get it right.
Um,
I'll tell you my story.
I,
you know,
I was in the semiconductor business and you know,
semiconductors was a great industry in the 90 days and then it almost died at
all the venture firms in the valley.
We're funding semiconductor companies,
uh,
and now nobody funds semiconductor companies.
Right?
So Pat,
I told,
you know,
I thought I would never work in semiconductors again.
The last company we did was in semiconductors.
So did you just never know.
And again,
it's all based on the team.
They had a convincing pitch of why that was a good opportunity and all the
issues that,
you know,
one would face with semiconductors,
which is kind of like forgot about them.
Um,
so anyways,
that's,
you know,
when we started the fund in 2013,
I think everyone was talking about block chain.
And then six months after it was Iot,
then was drones.
And today it's a,
I mean,
one of the best with told me that if you sprinkled it with AI in your deck,
you get funded.
Um,
so any information changes on pretty quickly.
we see it,
you know,
everybody's on AI something,
um,
where like,
well where's your,
do you have an engineer or something?
No,
but we'll hire them like,
okay.
So anyways,
we get it.
They get pounded us,
get it to,
they're smart.
What about VRN?
Autonomous.
Awesome.
I almost,
I also heard something last week,
which is interesting.
Oh yeah,
I you go Thomas driving.
He was on its way down.
I'm like,
it hasn't even made it
cool.
So I think at this point we can open up to questions from the audience.
Like what percentage of women were participants in the garage program since
you've done it for four years and do you do anything to try it
crude from that category?
Yes.
Um,
okay.
I'll tell you,
the first year we started garage,
um,
we did it with the two people that had the ACM group at Stanford.
And you know,
the way we started wearing like,
hey,
why don't you come up with a list of 20 people that we could reach out to?
Right?
So they came to us and,
and that 20 lists,
it was all guys like,
okay guys,
we need some diversity in this group.
Right?
So we had to force them to go find some women and I think we had in that garage
group we had four women,
uh,
to actually work color,
which is great.
Um,
but you know,
I was clearly not the majority cause we had about,
you know,
15 to 20 people give or take.
And every year,
the second year,
which we did a,
uh,
a call out for people,
the same ratios to be honest,
right?
We've tried really hard this year is actually going maybe the highest that we
have in terms of ratio,
but it's always under 50% for sure.
I would say around that,
around
30,
35%.
But we do some initiatives,
like for example,
we do,
we do a lot of hackathon at,
at our place.
The first hackathon was only for girls.
And you know,
the winner had dinner with John Dore,
which is like kind of life changing.
And if we look at our portfolio companies,
we have like pretty amazing female founders and you know,
we picked him because they're the best at what they do.
Not because their are,
are really exceptional in what they do.
So we don't wake up in the morning.
So next quarter we only fund men.
And then the recording one [inaudible] just this woman are just really
exceptional and happened to be the founders see you on.
We're very lucky to work with them.
Yeah.
It's almost,
it's recharged that we've done.
We didn't reach out for she plus plus,
which is a group at Stanford and uh,
I know it's a great group anyways.
And we hosted like some sort of a design thinking activity for them anyway,
this was maybe two years ago.
But out of that,
um,
we met,
uh,
our current engineering residents who happens to be a woman and she came from
that,
you know,
reach out program that we did.
So that was great.
Okay.
Um,
so you spoke about founders who have had,
who've lived the problem or have like experiences in some way.
As someone fresh out of college,
I'm interested in solving problems for enterprise because I see that the
software that is much worse than the stuff that we have as consumers,
but obviously like I've only ever worked at very tech forward companies like
Google,
very build our own solutions to all these problems.
Uh,
what are some,
what are some advice you might have for someone like me to either go get that
experience by itself with those problems or find people who have
I,
I have some,
some ideas with that.
So I think it should educate,
first of all,
I think you'd have to find,
I mean when you say the enterprise is just such a big place,
I think you should figure out where an enterprise you want to focus and get
educated and go to places.
As Martin mentioned,
there's so much information online you can find and there are so many groups you
can go and learn from them.
There are some conferences you can go but a little bit narrow it down.
And exactly what you mean by enterprise and,
and you're surrounded by yourself with the people who have done it before.
Ask questions.
Sometimes the best thing is to actually try to put something out.
Right.
And you know,
it's so,
I mean,
I want to say so easy.
You're glad.
It's relatively easy to kind of mock up some stuff and run it by people in
industry.
I Dunno if you have any ideas in mind,
but,
um,
that's what I encourage people to do in the garage when they don't know what
they're doing,
what w what to work on.
We actually bring speakers to tell them what problems they have.
That's how garage started.
So we would bring people from media or people who are real stay or ecommerce and
they would be like,
these are the problems we have.
And the students would actually say work because they would come up with
solutions because similar to you,
that's how it started.
They said,
we can code anything.
We just don't know what to Code.
Um,
and so anyways,
they're getting the feedback from people and I encouraged I Pashman set,
you can do the same but you almost want to take it a step further.
This is when you tell people I'm going to build this.
What do you think people are like,
oh yeah,
great,
great.
And people say like,
wait,
I have product market fit.
I'm going to go do it.
And truly until you tell somebody where you pay me for doing this,
uh,
then you know,
if you have truly product market fit and sometimes people just need to see a
little more than an idea in words or you know,
some sort of PowerPoint,
et cetera.
But I knew it was just stark.
That's my big advice.
That's the best way to finish.
One of the questions that we got is what advice do you have for someone at
Google who's interested in going into venture capital?
Talk to pair,
right?
No,
we are opened.
I actually just hired a person from Stanford business school that she,
she's actually in food,
so she worked for good eggs.
She was a chef before and then a given her expertise and background,
we are creating call for a startup in food.
So if you're interested in any particular way of being a venture capitalists,
it we'd love to talk to you.
And you know when you just,
when you think venture capital award from outside,
it looks like,
you know,
you sit down in a meeting and you look at page and then you provide some
feedback.
It's just one part of being of venture capitalists.
I think I would venture capitalists,
you'd have a really good deal flow I think if you don't have a good deal though,
you ended up picking wrong founders.
So if you're coming out of Google,
you have already a great community here.
That could be a good deal flow and you have to be able to pick winners.
So it takes time.
But just find your niche if you want to be a venture capitalist because it's
saturated market,
but it's always the industry looks for talented people.
Yeah.
And I want to say something about that because I think it's the same advice I
gave earlier is just the best ways to start.
And I think we live in a world where you don't have to wait and get permission
to get started.
Right?
So let's assume I want it to get into venture capitalists capital.
Now the first thing I would do is start doing some angel investing,
right?
I think a,
so if you're working at Google as an engineer,
I would guess you can use some percentage of whatever you're making every year
and devoted to do some angel investing,
right?
And just doing a couple of investment.
It's who's going to teach you so much about what it takes,
right?
You're just like passionate and is looks some way,
but once you get in it's kind of dirty and messy and it requires a lot of time,
et cetera.
Um,
the other saying that I think the world it has given us right now,
it was this amazing social media and you know,
the kind of digital access.
So there's a lot of people in the last five to 10 years that has built their own
brand.
Just by,
you know,
I have a podcast and I talk about something or to have a newsletter on AI or
whatever,
you know,
every day there's some new vertical or pitch that people do and they're getting
enough sourcing that they build their own deal flow to get going.
So anyways,
and again,
whoever answered endoring mysterious phase,
happy to chat more with them.
Some of the entrepreneurs I respect the most have either lost everything or been
on the verge of losing everything more than one time.
And they're so determined that that's okay.
They just started,
they throw caution to the wind.
Is that something you look for the people that if they didn't have any path to
funding from a group like yours,
that they would just figure out a way and be prepared to put everything at risk
for their idea?
Yeah.
So what do you look for?
Something that is a proxy of,
of this willingness to,
that you'd be willing to go the entrepreneurs that are really,
or they seem that they have gone bankrupt one or more times.
We're on the verge of it.
And I mean,
it's not backwards to say that we necessarily looking for,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
we do look for that person that is like,
I'm working on this.
Sometimes people come and it's like I'm starting this company,
but you know,
I'm working here in the meantime and,
you know,
they've been working and they could afford,
to quote quote,
to go do something full time and really commit.
Right?
So it's,
uh,
definitely a sign that we were,
you know,
who doesn't make us feel super cold feet about the founder.
Right.
But again,
everybody's different,
right?
And some people,
it doesn't mean because you have it easy,
you can't be a good founder on it.
Doesn't mean because you'll have it hard.
You're automatic.
Do you have good founder?
Right.
Misled business off exceptions.
That's
okay.
You know,
one of the hardest things I hear my friends say about at VC is,
um,
the bad ideas look just like the good ideas at first glance.
And when you become good,
you get thousands and thousands of deals coming across and you have to be able
to spot the ones that look back but are really,
really awesome.
Uh,
what are your secrets to doing that?
MMM hmm.
Okay.
I think is caught of the pattern recognition among the founders.
We typically want to meet founders.
Last year we met 2000 companies.
You've met 2000 companies.
Normally we,
you get about 10,000 beads and so on.
And because we do it so early,
we typically look at the idea where we really want to get to know the,
the founder.
Um,
and in part of it is just pattern recognition.
When you do it for so many years,
you just understand the characters of some of the founders.
But yes,
I mean like in,
in case of branch.
At the first idea was fitbit for dogs.
No.
Say it's the,
I don't,
and I think no one wants to do that,
but it was about the founding team and the character to build something and
their determination to do it.
That attracted us.
It's really hard.
I think there's a high error rate,
you know,
adventure.
It looks very glamorous.
We're only known for our successes,
not for our failures.
Right.
So we can invest in companies that don't make it and nobody knows or nobody
cares about the,
you know,
I think it was really important for the founders or we could miss 10 great
companies and it's nowhere to be seen.
Right.
So it's,
um,
you know,
it's,
I mean we have our own internal KPIs to see how we're doing and so on,
but,
um,
you know,
I think we're almost lucky that we're not measured externally on those misses.
But it's hard truth.
It's hard on everybody misses.
Right.
And I seeing on there like hard work and obsession.
Yeah.
You know,
gets you to be better at data of the day.
Do you have any notable misses that you can talk about?
Yes,
we do.
Uh,
you know,
it's early in the fund because,
so we may have missed more than I know of a,
I think we miss boxed witches up giant company.
It's like a Costco online.
And you know,
I think again,
if we had stuck by our principals,
sometimes it's like missing our principles.
It's really hard.
You say great founders,
uh,
something doesn't make sense,
but it's okay.
Uh,
you know,
and at the time it's like,
wow,
are they competing with Amazon who wants to compete with Amazon?
Um,
and it was a little later stage,
but you know,
we missed that company for example.
You know?
So what kind of advice do you give to the founders,
whether they're looking for new founders over there,
they're looking to break like first three or four people on the team.
What kind of characteristics or what advice you give them as they expand and
bringing new people in the team?
It's a good question and I think,
okay.
In general.
So I think there's two types of recruiting.
One is like your founding team and then,
you know,
obviously a lot of plies later to the next 10.
The first time people are the first 100 et cetera.
But,
um,
you know,
when you are,
if you're building that founding team,
I have this,
the most important advice.
Just take your time and actually be super focused.
That doing it takes time,
right?
It doesn't just happen by itself that all of a sudden you find you're founder
and he's a perfect thing.
It's because you're out there and you're trying to find this person,
right?
And you can't just hire the first person that comes along or bring our,
get together with the first person that comes along a,
because it's like finding a wife,
right?
For,
you know,
when you could marry your first girlfriend,
but maybe it was a bad idea.
Your first girlfriend was at 14.
I don't know.
Uh,
it's the same thing,
right?
So you have to be super patient,
uh,
at making the right choice.
That second thing is,
I think it's good to find people that are complimentary,
especially if you're starting from zero.
Um,
there's the,
you know,
if you want to pull out a company together,
you maybe need somebody.
Um,
you know,
that has it as an engineer,
front end engineer and a data scientist,
maybe on some person that's more than operations,
our sales or something,
right?
Sometimes it's one person that can do the three things,
Because you have a founder that is excellent at speaking to customers and
they've built everything and so on and they can just pull it out.
But sometimes you need two people,
sometimes you need three people.
Right?
And I think,
you know,
it's important to have the,
for me,
I think it's important.
I see it in companies when the critical components of the company I in the DNA
of that company from very,
very early on,
you'll have a higher chance of success.
Um,
not always the case,
but for another good example is if you're building a consumer brand,
you know,
some companies will say,
oh,
we're,
we have this great product and we'll hire a branding agency later,
right?
But if you are like a consumer companies,
good to have a consumer DNA early in the company for example,
and you should go find that person is like,
I call it the minimum viable team,
sort of the minimal viable product.
You know,
I want to add that um,
a lot of people can build product.
Not many
people can build companies.
So if you are looking for the co founder,
look for those people who have as more mentioned complimentary skills,
but it can help you both companies if you're looking for a VP of engineering as
a co founder is not enough to just be a great engineer.
As you build the product,
you just need to be able to attract talents.
So just spend a lot of family.
I learned that,
you know,
spend time socially tells a lot about crypto club person.
So get them out there,
go for a walk and just go see a ball game.
Just get to know them and just be patient and then making sure they have you
shared the same vision.
You know,
the,
the most difficult thing as an early stage investor is when founders can,
cannot get along.
You always can raise money,
you can always change the product and pivot.
But when you don't have the same vision and you can look eye to eye,
we can't fix it.
So a question for you all,
or when should someone go to YC?
It only because it's got so much mind shot here versus taking VC from CDC,
from a VC firm like yourself.
So that's the first question.
Or the second one is how do you differentiate yourself among other vcs?
Because you know,
for all of us here who live and breathe technology,
we hear of so many vcs all the time is 16 z has a very strong machine marketing
machine.
So how do you sort of a benchmark yourself against them to sort of stand out?
Um,
I think today they're pretty amazing accelerator out there including YC and they
have done a really good job last,
you know,
five to 10 years to hurry,
help founders from ground zero to get to the next stage.
And it all depends on your knee.
And what you can accomplish there.
Um,
there are other resources that you can use and not go through an accelerator.
But again,
I think it's case by case is very different.
Yes,
the venture capital community is just very crowded.
But again,
if you're looking for um,
people who can help you the first 24 months and help you build the foundation of
a long lasting company,
you need to look for venture capitalists who have that experience.
Um,
I think that their firm is set up to serve you in that and they take the risk
and they're able to,
to navigate the challenges that you have.
There are other vcs that you only go to them when you have product market fit
the of the customer and it can scale and you want to build an engineering team.
That's a different skillset.
We don't have that skill set.
Our DNA of our fund is helping founders in the ground zero,
especially in the first 24 months.
So that's where we set up.
But you know,
sequoia might be completed their friends,
you can go to them when you have customers and they can help you to become a
massive company.
Maybe a lot to say something that I think it's really important for founders.
There is multiple ways to get to build a deck company,
right?
Um,
there's no one single place you need to go to be successful at the end of the
company's work because of us.
But because of the founders and we're like really like support and we try very,
very hard to support them.
But at the end is really the founder that makes or breaks the company,
not us.
I hope.
I hope none of us anyways.
How would you guys,
or what sort of characterize is,
uh,
when you see someone who has been at Google for awhile,
like sort of like what are their characteristics?
He sort of in your mind picture when you,
when you see someone like that and then maybe particularly for product
management.
Um,
another way of asking is like,
what kinds of things should we like,
make sure we learn while we're here?
Good question.
Um,
well first of all,
maybe I will say some people who are passionate and says something smarter.
Um,
we love the PM role as a CEO for a company.
We think it's just like an amazing,
you know,
cause when you're a pm you're like a mini CEO,
right?
And when you're a CEO,
just have more responsibility because there's,
this is more,
you know,
I mean there's just,
you're on the edge all the time,
but it's a great experience.
And I think the more broad it is,
right?
Like all the way from customer to talking to the engineer,
um,
the better writer,
the more exposure,
the more projects,
etc. And seeing things from mental end,
right?
Because it's different.
Taking a project from zero to 80%,
then from 80% to 100% and getting it out there and following up.
What happens when you put it out and customers are using it,
etc. I don't know exactly how the PM thing is.
Work is organized here at Google.
I apologize,
but I know every company is slightly different,
but just all the way.
And I think broad,
that would be my,
my advice to you,
and it all depends if you're planning to start a company,
I think it depends on you.
You have to build your network year.
It's an amazing place.
You build a network.
Um,
I met the CEO who has building a great company.
We actually missed being an investor in that company and he was a pm of a large
company and he was telling me for four years it was pm every time he shipped the
product,
he then went to a smaller team and start from ground zero because he knew he was
to start a company.
So he was always uncomfortable being in a big team.
So he always requested the CTO,
CEO,
I manage to ship this product.
I just want to go start again from ground zero bill,
just give me more,
more tasks that I can do it and it,
speaking of that,
I have a request here.
As mark mentioned,
we think pms are companies are the best founders cov have seen because they're
their own CEO and if you're trying to build them a conference or a bootcamp
camp,
maybe this year or next year for PM's who want to start a company already
started it.
So we love to hear from you what type of topics you want to be covered so you
can email me page mount pair that we see.
I love to hear from you because you think it's just pretty,
pretty amazing place for us to partner with the future founders.
Okay.
Uh,
you mentioned like reaching out and getting help from people.
That's always something I've
been nervous about.
Uh,
when asking for help from someone like yourselves who are busy individuals,
do you have advice for how to ask for help?
Like should I go when it's a well formed clearly scope,
like 32nd question.
Do you have,
are are people like yourselves interested in having kind of open ended kind of
broader discussions as well?
You know,
I always found the people reach out to me.
They're very,
very specific.
I respond,
I always respond.
But the ones that are very specific,
I make time.
But the ones that say sell,
can I have a coffee?
I want to run an idea by you.
It just not that specific.
I don't know how I can help with an accurate,
just so busy.
So just be very,
very specific and park it to people who can really help you and even passionate
about the topic you want to discuss with them.
I think,
you know,
I meet more people,
I'm like lower bit,
lower a bar I would say.
But I think for me when people tell me their story again like hey,
I'm a Google or I've been working on this for a long time and I'm thinking of
doing this,
do you want to have a chat with me?
And if I have time I definitely will do it.
You know?
So,
but again,
sell yourself if you don't have a company to sell,
sell yourself.
Yeah,
and actually this goes back to when you go fundraise.
I think sometimes if you tell your story is as important as your product and
metrics.
And,
and most of the founders I'm shy away to say that to tell their stories be they
actually pushed them.
They start to say,
oh,
where did you grow up?
How did you do?
And so we just want to get to know them.
So when you go pitch,
don't,
don't be shy way to tell your stories.
What was the hardest part for start?
I,
after you've started VC,
what was your hardest thing that you know,
took to get used to like where did you struggle?
Lowers some common pitfalls early on you had mentioned,
uh,
like trying to create,
you know,
like a linear regression,
all these parameters,
trying to optimize and trying to bring in from time to next optimization here.
Um,
other,
other things that you struggled with?
You know,
I think today even to look at this is like three and a half years.
Finally you have like over
60 companies that we have invested.
So finding the time to help these people while we still serve the community.
It's a big challenge for us are,
that's why we building a team as an angel investor.
So before that I was an Indian investor.
When you're doing an angel investment,
you just keep investing,
just invest.
And every new company you invest very excited to go to next one and you are
managing get fun.
You want to invest in 30 40 companies.
So you have to have a discipline to the concentrated portfolio.
That's a big difference.
Um,
every company we invest today,
that means more or less company and next three years.
So,
but even when you're an angel investor and you never think about it,
you just keep investing.
I think for me the hardest thing was like,
imagine you're,
you know,
you're being an operator all your life and all of a sudden you were an investor.
So I think for the first year I'm like,
you know,
we didn't have that many companies.
When you start,
you don't have any companies,
right?
So passion knows the story.
But I remember,
you know,
one Sunday I was there and I was like writing code for one of the companies.
So like,
okay,
that's not right.
Uh,
so,
but that's your,
you know,
there's a lot of inertia and what we do as humans.
So,
uh,
you know,
I,
I not longer doing that,
but so that was my hardest adjustment,
knowing that I can't do it.
My job is to teach somebody how to do it all,
suggest how to do it.
They have to make the decisions,
but I shouldn't do it every several years.
There are new,
big trends in the industry,
so there are a lot of things that are very hot right now,
like a self driving car,
VR,
ar,
AI and sexual.
So like,
uh,
how do you evaluate those fields at sexual?
Like how do you think about those trends right now and then what would be big
things that can change the world has changed the industry in the several,
in the next like five or 10 years.
Every year,
right?
Every 10 years.
There's like this big change that has happened in the valley.
Right.
And I liked to tell the story,
but in 76,
it was the PC,
right?
10 years later,
they 86 and it was maybe the router and then you later in [inaudible] 96 so it
was the internet.
10 years later,
you know,
six was the iPhone.
So people are like,
what's happened now in 2016 has already passed.
Right?
And I tell people it's probably an Nvidia Gpu processor that's probably the neck
is like a Nicole and off that router.
Um,
and a lot of things,
the fact that we're,
you know,
when I was doing my phd,
we,
you know,
I was doing convex optimization,
which almost the anti deep learning way of doing,
solving a problem,
um,
and the deep learning people at Stanford,
they couldn't even run a little 20 circuit,
you know,
amplify or they can size it,
right?
And,
you know,
fast forward 17 years,
you can do amazing things with deep learning.
So it this platforms that take place like the iPhone or the Internet,
it's not something that just changes,
uh,
you know,
a particular behavioral changes,
industries,
inches,
you know,
um,
the enterprise a change as media.
I changed as a consumer.
It changes everything,
right?
Uh,
in the case of that Nvidia Gpu,
I think the same is going to happen.
We're at the very,
very beginning and a lot of technology cycles,
they're like second or their systems,
they overshoot and then they go back,
right?
So the internet,
everybody was like overpriced and then it kind start off.
Same with mobile apps,
with everything.
Um,
so now we're in the cycle where everybody's super excited about AI and or VR and
ar.
Even VR.
Ar I think is a steal even still a little early on the investment cycle.
Um,
but you know,
you,
you have to do your homework as an investor if in our job,
right,
when you say AI,
not all AI was created equal,
I think,
right?
For some cases you absolutely need to be 100% accurate.
For some cases it's okay if you're 80% and you can build a product around it,
maybe we won't be 100% for another five years.
I'm telling and those are the sort of little things that we are evaluated.
But again at the end we're thinking it all goes back to the founders,
the founder,
you know,
aware of where they are and where he is and the limitations of what they have
and so on.
Anyways,
you know,
I suffer more Livey followed.
I mean we,
we are aware of trends where we don't follow trends and if you think when it's
hot,
it's already too late to invest.
I think you want to partner with founders who see future before anybody else and
you partner with them.
And if you look at the best companies ever created,
the Renard in any hot space is look stock market and it's too hard.
It's too late to buy.
You want to make sure you buy those stocks at the time that not many people
know.
And you know,
for us he's just really,
rather than looking for what is hot,
we look for outliers.
For those founders who are determined to build something really massive in the
market,
that they believe it exists and we can help them.
And you know,
in this cycles,
it really is like at this overshoot,
you know,
the best companies almost get funded four to five years after people start
realizing,
you know,
the big change.
You know,
it's like,
um,
you know,
even when Google was founded,
it was not,
it was not at Yahoo.
Right.
It was a little later or Uber and he's a little later after the iPhone,
you know,
it wasn't,
it's like radical change.
Maybe it takes a little bit of time.
All right,
well thank you.
Are Out of time,
but it was really great.
Thank you for him.
Thank you.
Oh,
good question.
Yeah.
[inaudible].